hey guys I'm out of the country at the
moment but we didn't want to leave you
hanging with no clips so here's just
some general Insanity of the day former
president Trump is going to be on CNN
yeah he should be
he should be look you know you've
already gotten criticism remember what
John Malone said let's get some real
journalists now you try to get some real
journalists and you're getting hit CNN
for getting rid of man has the greatest
journalists and the largest group of
journalists in the world in in the
Ukraine Poland and Russia we have over
86 people on the ground we're not at it
we're not reporting an opportunity
divided government right we need to hear
both voices that's what you see
Republicans are on the air on CNN
Democrats are on there MSNBC voices
should be heard of David suddenly MSNBC
is is a real force to be reckoned with
with some of the problems that fox has
had is CNN going to Philadelphia there
are a number of advocacy networks Out
There Our focus is if it could be a
network about like us to fax the best
version of The Facts as Carl Bernstein
would say great journalism and not just
politics either but when we do politics
we need to represent the questions but I
think it's important for America so I
think it's a very admirable goal for
America the question to me is a slightly
different one which is does it rate and
maybe that's an unfair and terrible
question to ask but that underneath it
is the business question well look we
got a great political season coming
this is a new CNN we're focused on
for the country
in terms of the I know I know news
that'll become some people don't like
the choice some people don't like the
choice look I'm very excited about my
friend Gail doing the show King Charles
which I think is the greatest name TV TV
news history
so well I'm proud of CNN we're on a
great journey and this country needs it
journalism facts broad aperture but do
you think that can be as profitable as
as a as what it used to be I believe in
great Brands I believe in what Ted
created it inspired me to get in this
business and you build a great brand and
in a long time you're going to have a
lot more value we get it right we take
it around the world you know we will be
stronger today we have 150 million
people a month that come to cnn.com you
probably if you check your phone on any
given day that's us so I think we got a
nice Foundation we're focusing on
getting it right big Rebrand coming up
in June with with Chris Licht right a
lot happening there because you've got
some work to do because it's keeping the
name I know but the the I mean things
have not improved yet in terms of rain a
lot of it has I mean I think people
don't talk about just raw ratings it's
well you know for us the focus is let's
get the message right let's get the
brand right let's get the balance right
and the rest of it will come what do you
think about Fox News that's what I was
that opens up opportunities does it not
our focus is to do a great oh you're
saying what we do best that's no longer
was it an advocacy Network CNN
everybody's got to make a judgment on
everyone based on how they feel I can
tell you it wasn't advocacy let me just
tell you yes it would be for you Joey
it's advocating today talk about it
Andrew you're going to watch Trump on
CNS why wouldn't I I think he's the
front runner he has to be we're happy
that yeah well the last guy wouldn't
have put him on probably even if he was
a front ruler I don't know about that no
I do I don't know what dude it's a
longer conversation David Zazzle we
appreciate you thank you guys